[Music]
So girl's money is a
really very rare product that you can't find
everywhere in stores and
in confectionery shops, that above
all the taste of fruit that has just been
picked, we're really in something
something very special a
negotiation of a good or fricon son
to have him on the fly for a long time and
that's a real pleasure
descriptive
youth
[Music]
my name is worse the ladies years old I am a
confectioner to his friend and I represent  the
fifth generation of
candied fruit confectioner
then a madman confides at the base is
canned fruit by sugar and
it is the idea of being able to preserve fruit
which have a very short
lifespan once picked and
there the idea is really to be able
to keep them for several years in
their sugar syrup
the most popular candied fruits
are perhaps melon apricot strawberries
and orange we take a fruit that we put
in a clear syrup and  by
successive broth we eliminate its natural state
to preserve it preserve it after
all the tour tomorrow there is all the know-
how to experience the confectioners to
manage to have a fruit that will be
soft that will not go into jam
that will hold together that will  have taste
that we don't even try to make
large volumes we just try to
work with quality fresh fruit products
but that's what makes this
difference there that's what makes us
above the rest
the tradition of making money has existed in
provence for a very long time our
story began in 1866 and since then we
have passed the baby on from father to son it has
passed like this from generation to
generation
[Music]
the